[Música]
y llegamos directo a venezuela y esta
lista a nuestra corresponsal daniela
zambrano alien a muy buen día hablemos
de lo que dijo ayer eeuu que informó que
va a retirar algunas sanciones
económicas a venezuela le pregunto qué
es lo que se va a levantar
hola qué tal muy buen día lo que se
conoce hasta el momento es el
levantamiento de sanciones energéticas
que van a permitir que la trasnacional
estadounidense chevron y la estatal
venezolana petróleos de venezuela puedan
retomar conversaciones sin embargo se
hablaba de que no se iba a permitir al
menos expresamente por ahora ni la
perforación ni la exportación de crudo
venezolano tan solo hablar era imposible
hasta hace algunos meses según las
sanciones de eeuu por esto estaba
totalmente prohibido ahora podrían
reanudar esas conversaciones según
explicaban funcionarios estadounidenses
pero llama la atención que del si
rodríguez vicepresidenta de venezuela
desea través de un twitter que
confirmaba que el gobierno
estadounidense iba a permitir o había
permitido que ahora empresas tanto
europeas como
estadounidenses pudieran reactivar
operaciones en venezuela otra de las
decisiones que habría tomado eeuu sería
levantar la sanción a uno de los
funcionarios de la administración de
nicolás maduro que estamos sancionados
de 2017 se trata de carlos malpica
flores quién es este funcionario el
sobrino es y las flores esposa del
presidente nicolas maduros y además era
ex funcionario de pedevesa manejaba las
finanzas esto hasta el momento es lo que
se conoce sin embargo imagino que
también se anunciarán otras el
levantamiento de sanciones recordemos
que eeuu ha dicho además que esto irá
acorde con las negociaciones que avancen
entre el gobierno de nicolás maduro y la
oposición venezolana en mexico para
eventualmente unas elecciones
presidenciales libres y transparentes el
asesor de la casa blanca para américa
tal idea decía que si no había avances
en las negociaciones pues se volverían a
imponer sanciones claro de angeli
también pues hay que esperar a ver
cuando se implementa todo este tema con
el petróleo venezolano y estas empresas
que usted mencionó porque mire lo que
pasó con estas empresas públicas que
todavía pues no se ha concretado esta
salida viene a la bolsa pero volvamos al
tema que nos concierne el día de hoy qué
reacciones hay en venezuela después del
anuncio del gobierno estadounidense
la primera reacción fue la
vicepresidenta del si rodríguez a través
de twitter ella decía que esperaba que
esté en camino para que se levantaran
todas las sanciones que el gobierno
estadounidense había impuesto a la
administración de nicolás maduró de los
funcionarios particulares posteriormente
se conoció un comunicado de la
denominada plataforma unitaria que es la
coalición de los principales partidos
opositores en el que se anunciaba que
formalmente se renovaban conversaciones
con el gobierno de nicolás maduro para
reactivar el diálogo en mexico llamó la
atención una fotografía que se difundió
por parte de los negociadores de ambas
partes jorge rodríguez en el presidente
de la asamblea nacional y gerardo blyde
efe negociador de la oposición
difundieron una foto en twitter con las
manos estrechadas diciendo que estaban
trabajando en conjunto luego también se
conoció un comunicado de esta plataforma
unitaria diciendo que negaban
rotundamente que ellos hayan solicitado
a estados unidos levantar sanciones a
particulares esto por el caso que les
acabo de comentar de carlos malpica
flores y porque más temprano había
trascendido que esta decisión de eeuu de
levantar o por lo menos aliviar algunas
sanciones económicas contra venas era
petición e incluso de la oposición
venezolana ellos quisieron aclarar que
las sanciones personales impuestas a
funcionarios sobre todo en materia de
corrupción no era una solicitud de por
lo menos la plataforma unitaria